cuando vamos al médico o cuando
cumplimos años es muy común que nos mida
pero cómo mide esta altura nuestra
altura se mide desde nuestros pies hasta
dónde termina nuestra cabeza pero si
queremos medir la altura de un triángulo
como lo harías un triángulo no tiene
cabeza y menos de ir al médico primero
hay que asegurarnos de que uno de los
lados del triángulo esté horizontal si
nuestro triángulo es un poco travieso y
no tiene ningún lado así tendrás que
girarlo para que veas uno de sus lados
de manera horizontal no importa el lado
que sea una vez que seleccionamos un
lado y lo ubicamos en horizontal ya
podemos saber qué tan alto es nuestro
triángulo es decir podemos medir su
altura igual que cuando nos miden a
nosotros en el triángulo tenemos que ir
en línea recta desde la base hasta el
punto más alto que es el vértice de
arriba entonces lo que mide esta línea
será la altura del triángulo
sin embargo podemos girar el triángulo y
tener otra base y por lo tanto tendremos
otra altura aunque nosotros nos iremos
si nos acostemos seguiremos teniendo la
misma altura pero en los triángulos la
altura cambia dependiendo de qué base
tomemos vamos a seguir con el mismo
triángulo pero si lo giramos y ahora
ponemos como base este otro lado
entonces tendrá otra altura porque ahora
el punto más alto es otro
es importante que la altura esté
completamente perpendicular a la base si
no se forma un ángulo de 90 grados
la medida será incorrecta como te das
cuenta un triángulo tendrá tres alturas
diferentes porque si lo giramos cada uno
de sus lados puede ser considerado como
su base trazamos la altura que nos falta
para este triángulo así que vamos a
tomar como base el último lado
nuevamente la altura es la línea recta
que está perpendicular a la base y que
llega al punto más alto del triángulo
hay triángulos un poco más alocados que
tienen lados muy alargados o muy
inclinados pero aún así tienen sus tres
alturas debes poner atención cuando
encuentres este tipo de triángulos para
trazar y poder medir la altura de estos
triángulos es importante que recuerdes
que la altura es una línea perpendicular
a la base por lo que se tienen que
formar ángulos de 90 grados
tomando esto en cuenta y una vez que
decidimos que el lado será nuestra base
vamos a trazar la altura de este
triángulo parece que la altura no es
perpendicular a la base porque no se
tocan es como si la altura estuviera
flotando pero no pasa nada esta altura
es correcta para comprobarlo sólo hay
que continuar la línea de la base y
asegurarnos que la altura sea
perpendicular lo ve por un momento creí
que era una altura impostora pero no
resultó ser la correcta ten cuidado con
estas líneas que se hacen pasar por
alturas que no te vayan a engañar